Françoise Hardy qu'est-ce que vous
mettez sur les lèvres là
de l'anti cernes j'élève très foncé
j'aime pas ça c'est pas joli alors je
mets quelque chose pour les éclaircir
et pourquoi votre démaquillez pas les
lèvres
oh c'est simplement parce que j'ai les
lèvres sèches je ne supporte pas le
rouge à lèvres
ni quoi que ce soit d'ailleurs sur les
lèvres
non non autrement je mettrai un rouge
clair ou quelque chose
[Musique]
que les lèvres pâles c'est beaucoup plus
joli que lèvres rouge ou lèvres foncé et
quel est le principe de votre maquillage
Dieu
[Musique]
nous avons cherché comme effet oh je ne
cherche aucun effet je sais pas je mets
du noir
sur la paupière enfin de l'ail Shadow ça
s'appelle puis je fais le trait avec de
l'eye-liner puis je fais un trait au
crayon en dessous voilà